salve guarda tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovo video il primo che
registro nel 2021 pensavate che il 2020
potreste essere l'anno con più sorprese
della storia ovviamente probabilmente il
continuum spazio temporale con la sera
su se stesso visto che adesso fa vj alla
barba o meglio un accenno di barba un
una poca peluria una radura in mezzo
alla foresta ecco questa cosa è successo
e cosa andremo a fare perché questo
l'esperimento e probabilmente sarà
l'anatema del 2021 dire che la barba
allora sono andato dai miei genitori per
natale ok sono partito il 20 e sono
stato lì fino alla fine dell'anno quindi
una decina di giorni o poco più
mi sono dimenticato il rasoio a casa io
non è a me non è che la barba non cresce
semplicemente vi cresce strana mi piace
strana quindi o mera taglio e ci scherza
sempre sopra sul fatto che non ho la
barba
però quando ero a torino mi sono appunto
dimenticato come vi dicevo rasoi a
milano e non mi sono tagliato la barba
per paio di settimane questo è il
risultato non era mai successo perché io
italia sia barber cosiddetto non era mai
successo ed è stranissimo
adesso vi dico che se dicevo perché
all'inizio non hai mai avuto la barba
nei baffi fa male di far strano se siete
la prof.sa male nel senso che io mi sono
fatto cresce la prima fila barba per la
prima volta esempi all'inizio la prima
settimana sentivo proprio il peso della
peel urlo sentivo proprio il peso e mi
minimi da mi bruciava tutto qua è stato
orribile
la seconda cosa che invece mi ha dato
fastidio quando tipo baby io ero vele
genere ti l'imatinib ha figli rimangono
bagnati e da un po magari ti cade una
gocciolina la roma mi fa schifo e se io
sono tutto il giorno fobico schizzinoso
quindi fatto che che schifo e vaff
siamo arrivati oggi nel 2021 quest'anno
spegne io vi auguro a tutti innanzitutto
buon anno anche se avevo fatto già in
live
il 31 quando abbiamo fatto la rai tre ed
è stato mega complicato perché io 31
dicembre quando gli ho fatto gli auguri
di capodanno ho fatto una live
ok fortuna live dove si vedeva già che
avevo don così ma avevo già un po la
barba i commenti erano solo su quello di
regalare la sega nessuno le 2021 tutti
ormai la barba ma che è successo a
mayotte e quindi ho detto perché sta
roba farà scalpore quindi vediamo di non
spoilerare più e nella live scorsa ho
fatto questo dopo un po però mi sono
accorto che effettivamente bastava anche
solo questo questo per non spoilerare
questa cosa qua incredibile ora questa
cosa che state vedendo è l'inizio è
l'incipit perché voglio fare un
esperimento ragazzi voglio che questo
2021 mi porti la vecchiaia io prima di
dimostravo 16 tutto in colpo neo 30
quindi voglio vedere che cosa succede se
lascio la barba per tutto il 2021
non sono sicuro che riuscirò a farla
perché magari certo punto tentato il
suicidio dal fastidio però l'intento e
questo poi magari a un certo punto di
fermi di ragazzi già faccio più ho
resistito hicks giorni cioè domani però
l'intento è quello di durare per tutto
il 2021 e in italia rli a capodanno ma
chi me lo fa fare
se vedete a me l'aveva cresce strana la
stessa mi cresce a chiazze mi cresce a
chiazze poi quando incendi cuoce della
barba qua non c'è niente face più barba
cioè non mi cresce uniforme
questa cosa non ha senso proviamo a fare
un esperimento che non è diretto da
kartoffeln che i baffi ce li ha
disegnati ma proprio dal fare igieniche
dei fatti originali la prima cosa che vi
chiedono i commenti e se vedendovi così
è meglio prima o dopo sinceri non con
mia madre che mi dice ma che sembri un
barbone fai schifo babai a lavarti
voglio proprio un commento sincero sei
molto meno fregno molto più freni
spero vi sia piaciuto raga come
il momento è un bel mi piace anche per i
social che trovate nella descrizione se
non siete tutti iscritti e non ci
vediamo ad un prossimo colpo di baffo
[Musica]